dafür sprechen wir jetzt aber mit max
kieve er hat die reportage den beitrag
den sie gerade gesehen haben gemacht er
war mit der us border control unterwegs
wie ist denn jetzt dein fazit nach
dieser geschichte bringt die mauer
wirklich sicherheit ja am wochenende gab
es hier in den usa eine meldung die
wirklich hat aufhorchen lassen
an der grenze hat die polizei crystal
meth eingesammelt und gefunden und zwar
so viel dass man damit jeden mann jede
frau und jedes kind in den usa hätte
versorgen können das zeigt wie groß
dieses drogenproblem wirklich ist und ja
an der grenze hat man uns gesagt die
mauer hilft uns aber zur wahrheit gehört
eben auch unter der ägide von trump sind
knapp 600 kilometer mauer gebaut worden
und ehrlicherweise der großteil davon
der stand schon vorher der es unter jump
nur ausgebaut worden insofern das fazit
fällt am ende wahrscheinlich gemischt
aus du bist in einem vorort von los
angeles also kalifornien da wo man
eigentlich trump gegner ist wenn ich mir
das im hintergrund so anschaut sieht das
aber ganz anders aus was ist da los
ja es ist eine wahnsinns party hier seit
heute morgen um 9 uhr
wir können ja mal zu einem der autos ran
laufen christian kommt man mit
das sind alles tram fans extra germany
wird
und das ist eben wirklich erstaunlich
das ist hier kalifornien das ist eine
demokratische herzkammer man würde
denken joe biden gewinnt hier mit
riesigem vorsprung aber auch hier
gewinnt gelingt es dem jump lager leute
zu mobilisieren die mit ihren trucks mit
ihren pick-ups mit ihren autos
hergekommen sind und hier eine große
party seit heute morgen feiern
max priebe vielen dank an dich du in den
usa
vielen dank für den moment mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren